Sherlock the lying detective warning
right now not spoiler-free spoilers will
abound across this whole thing now let
me start by saying if you saw my review
for the six thatcher's you know I didn't
like that episode I actually got kind of
ranty talking about that episode so this
one had a bit to pick up from to get me
back on board did it do it yes it did
this episode's good it's very good it's
frickin great this was a terrific
episode and I loved just about
everything that's going on here
I loved John and I loved how real they
are making his pain and I loved the
interaction that he has with his
hallucination of Mary and that's the
sort of thing that can go off the rails
but I liked it because I always liked
their dynamic together I thought they
had great chemistry together and it's
nice getting that dynamic back but it
never felt like cheating it didn't feel
like bringing Mary back because she's
always constantly reminding him I'm just
in your head I'm still you so I like
that whole thing and it felt like a
really nice sort of just farewell note
to truly put the character to bed so I
like that I really like where Sherlock
went and how far down the rabbit hole of
addiction he went this because we you
know it's been in there since the
beginning that Sherlock tends to have an
addiction issues especially if he's not
in the middle of the case and we've even
seen him like get found in like a drug
den or whatever but he's always bounced
back very quickly we've never truly seen
how South things can go for him now
we're seeing it and it's really
fascinating I found it so interesting
that that even when he's completely
drunk doubt it can um kind of his his
conscious mind but his subconscious
keeps making deductions even if he
doesn't want it to and I'd like the
whole idea he has to like play catch up
to his own brain and this whole idea
that it's like he's still making
deductions and he's still saying and
doing things based on those deductions
but he doesn't
why because his more conscious thing he
mind just is stumbling through the steps
that subconsciously he's already blown
through that's a really interesting
realization of him being really drugged
out it works very very well Toby Jones
Toby Jones as culverton Smith I was
looking forward to him because I loved
Toby Jones I really loved him in villain
moment I mean I loved him as the dream
master and Doctor Who so based off that
I was really looking forward to this oh
man he is everything about him is just
unnerving just this slight this way of
talking that it's not quite a speech
impediment but there's something just
off and the teeth they gave him he's got
this one tooth it's just kind of the
sideways thing and it's just it's not
awful but it's just slightly I like
everything about him just makes you
uncomfortable in this sort of
something's not right way and just that
feeling permeates the character in the
performance and it works so so well and
it's interesting when I think about it
because this is the kind of guy he's not
really out thinking or outsmarting or
even well he's trying out smarter life
but he's not really quite pulling that
off and if Sherlock was truly on his
game and wasn't you know completely
whacked out on drugs this guy would
probably not stand a chance and normally
that a villain that only works because
the hero is handicapped is a problem for
me in this case it's not because the
show isn't trying to play that game
really because they make up for the fact
that he's probably not Sherlock's
intellectual equal the way certainly
more we already was or Irene Adler was
Orion Magnuson was Colton Smith's not at
that level but he is so skeevy I mean
Sherlock calls him a monster and that is
the perfect word that makes up for the
fact that normally he probably wouldn't
be that much of a challenge for Sherlock
and that that so that is balanced really
well I think I need to single out though
for me the real MVP of this episode mrs.
Hudson Oh
I mean I've always liked mrs. Hudson but
the highlight she gets in this episode
how much fun she gets to have she's good
Sherlock in the trunk just the fact that
she even has that card she has to keep
reminding John I'm not your housekeeper
I was married to a drug lord I own
property this is my stuff I have a life
I just I love all of that and I like
that Sherlock was he they really found a
really good balance with how sort of
hampered he was by the drugs because he
comes up with a solution that is not
Sherlock's most clever solution in terms
of just finding a way to record the guy
confess that's kind of a it's kind of a
basic solution you know basic for him
but it's still good enough and he's just
clever enough and I'd like that sort of
smiling again something about the number
three people stopped looking once
they've gotten to three this episode was
so so good now I considered banging out
this review immediately after watching
it and ultimately I didn't do that I
decided to sleep on it and think about a
little bit more not to sort of solidify
my thinking about the episode itself I
knew I loved it I loved it immediately
but I need to figure out if this alters
my opinion of the six thatcher's at all
because honestly without the six
thatcher's we don't get this if Mary
doesn't die then we don't have this tear
between Watson and Holmes and I like how
that played out we don't see John in
this much pain I like how that played
out we don't see you know Sherlock laid
Lowen in the face of addiction again no
harder than we've ever seen and I liked
how that played out so now realising
that do I like the six thatcher's any
better no not really
because here's the thing I think people
thought I was upset because they killed
Mary you know people would tell me you
know she was killed in the books it's
part of the Canon they weren't married
that like it wasn't the fact that she
died that annoyed me what annoyed me
about that episode was that they had
they undermined John and Mary's
relationship immediately before killing
her which I didn't think was necessary
in the first place and I really didn't
like it because the way they did it was
basically a complete retread of the way
they have brought the relationship into
question in the episode where they got
married so that was the thing so while I
will grant it wasn't
Cerie for Mary to die nothing about what
was great about this episode and what
was necessary from the previous episode
required the undermining of John and
Mary's relationship we didn't need her
to run off again that that nothing about
that contributed to this episode the
only part of undermining their
relationship that did contribute was
that one woman on the bus which that
some of you are probably wondering is he
going to talk about that and I'm kind of
not because I've got enough thoughts
about that that I actually want to do a
separate video talking about just that
because it's gonna go into some amount
of speculation about what's coming next
but I will say this what I'll say is I
like the reveal I like how it's done I
think that they did a wonderful job
taking an actress in with nothing but
very hair basic hair and makeup changes
and just a voice change did a wonderful
job of concealing her because I didn't
see that coming I mean I called that
there was something up with the daughter
almost immediately I certainly didn't
call what happened though but the more I
think about what they actually revealed
the more I'm really worried about it
within the confines of this episode like
it loved it
excellent but I'm really am worried
about how they're gonna pull it off in
the next episode and I'm gonna talk
about that in a separate video so that's
gonna wrap it up for me so the lion
detective have you seen it I hope so cuz
otherwise I've spoiled a crap ton of
stuff for you actually maybe not that
much I kind of I didn't go into plot
specifics as much as I would think in
any case if you've seen it what do you
think about it whatever you thought drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe wouldn't mind if you hit that
Bell down there so you get notifications
when I put new stuff up follow me on
Twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned